1998 I'll never forget it
it was the year when those grisly
murders occurred in the Arklay mountains
soon after the news was out to the whole
world revealing that it was the fault of
a secret viral experiment conducted by
the international pharmaceutical
Enterprise umbrella the virus broke out
in a nearby mountain community Raccoon
City and hit the peaceful little town
the devastating well crippling it's very
foundation not taking any chances the
President of the United States ordered a
contingency plan to sterilize records
city
with the whole affair gone public the
United States government issued an
indefinite suspension of business decree
to umbrella soon its stock prices
crashed and for all intents and purposes
umbrella was finished
[Music]
six years of assets that are rendus
incident I received special training via
a secret organization working under the
direct control of the president I was to
assume the responsibility of protecting
the new president's family why am I the
one who always gets the sword another
snake
yeah
you are a long way from home cowboy
you'll have my sympathies guess that's a
locals way of breaking the ice anyway
you know what this is all about my
assignment is to search for the
president's missing daughter right on by
yourself I'm sure you boys didn't just
tag along so we could sing Kumbaya
together at some boys Scout bonfire then
again maybe you did yo crazy it's a
direct order from the chief himself I
tell you it's no big Nick I'm counting
on you guys
it was right before I was to take on my
duties of protecting the president's
daughter when she was abducted
that's the ultimate reason I'm in this
lonely and rural part of Europe
according to our intelligence
there's reliable information about a
sighting of a girl that looks very
similar to the president's daughter
apparently she's being withheld by some
unidentified group of people who would
have thought that my first job would
have been a rescue mission it's freezing
so cold all of us on it
must be my imagination
sorry it took so long
you
[Music]
discipline is the variance I'll go and
have a look around we stand watch that
guard don't want to get any parking
tickets right parking tickets good luck
jeez who are these guys did you say
something
Leon I hope you can hear me I'm Ingrid
Hanigan I'll be your support on this
mission loud and clear somehow I thought
you'd be a little older so the subjects
name is Ashley Graham right that's right
she's the daughter of the president so
try to behave yourself okay whoever this
group is they sure picked the wrong girl
to kidnap I'll try to find some more
information on my end as well good talk
to you later
Leon out
[Applause]
excuse me sir I was wondering if you
might recognize a girl in this
photograph get cut off which does not
get lucky little otter got they cover
all sorry too about it
freeze
see freeze
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is everything okay
there was a hostile local I had no
choice but to neutralize him there's
still other surrounding the area get out
of there and head toward the village
take whatever measures necessary to save
the subject understood
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for us
[Applause]
Oh
we'll send because your
the rule said we can eat you
Master bee Percy
looking born up this order they decide
they name or ski years
[Music]
Lord Satya first everyone going bingo
[Music]
[Applause]